so we had a big workshop and an
associate was responsible for preparing
this workshop and the workshop was a lot
about product line strategy lots of
numbers prepared for that there were
board level members attending this
Workshop we as a consulting firm and
also Partners flying in for the meeting
attending it because it just was so
important to the project that we were
conducting it was quite a complex
session there were numbers printed out
on the wall on big wallpers that then we
were supposed to discuss with the
clients and after starting this
discussion about 20 minutes into the
workshop it became clear that all the
numbers that were prepared that were
presented were actually wrong so
apparently that associate pulled numbers
from a wrong Financial year or something
like that and unfortunately no one
noticed until then at some point one of
the clients noticed that and surely this
was extremely unfortunate and surely
also extremely embarrassing for us as
consultants preparing the session